le ferroviaire au coeur du plan de
relance du gouvernement près de 5
milliards d'euros de ce plan iront à la
sncf le train fait son grand retour à la
faveur de la transition énergétique
il se pose comme une alternative à
l'aérien et au transport routier
mais les défis sont nombreux ouverture à
la concurrence gestion de la préco vide
au final l'entreprise publique est elle
vraiment la grande gagnante de ce plan
on obtient tel qu'un répit on en parle
tout de suite avec l'économiste jacques
sapir bienvenue jeanne bonsoir à vous
bonsoir c'est fanny alors jacques à
comment se présente l'avenir de la sncf
qui semble plutôt avantagé par ce plan
de relance présenté au début du mois oui
indiscutablement avec 4,7 milliards pour
la sncf présent dans le plan de relance
c'est une bonne nouvelle
il faut ajouter à cela évidemment que le
gouvernement a présenté une forme de
deux plans de relance ou de plans de
priorité pour le transport ferroviaire
il voudrait justement substituer le
train un certain nombre de voyages en
avion relancer le fret relancer les
trains nuit dont tout ça en apparence ce
sont d'excellentes nouvelles sauf que
malheureusement la sncf sort du
confinement et avant de la grève qu'il y
avait eu fin 2019 début 2020 assez
affaibli et on peut se demander si elle
pourra justement un profiter de cette
situation qui devrait lui être pourtant
favorable alors que représente un
jacques le volet transports au sein de
la partie transition écologique du plan
de relance
alors il faut savoir que dont le plan de
relance il ya grosso modo 30 milliards
d'euros qui sont destinées si vous
voulez à la transition écologique
sur ces 30 milliards il y en a 11
milliards qui sont destinés aux
problèmes des transports et sur ses onze
billard justement on a les 4 7 milliards
pour la sncf
alors ça semble effectivement important
et d'une certaine manière c'est d'autant
plus important que le gouvernement avant
la crise de lakovic 19 et bien a repris
à sa charge une grosse partie de la
dette de la sncf fin 2019 la dette de la
sncf s'était 60 milliards d'euros dont
52 milliards rien que pour le
réseau et là le gouvernement il a repris
22 milliards donc on se dit voilà c'est
un effort qui est quand même un effort
extrêmement important oui mais quand on
regarde ce que pèsent ces 4 7 milliards
surtout déjà à côté des 22 milliards qui
ont été décidé bien avant la crise de
lakovic 19 eh bien on peut se dire que
malgré tout il ya peut-être une certaine
ambiguïté dans la force de ce plan alors
jaloux vous dites que ces difficultés se
sont plutôt aggravées avec le
confinement
oui tout à fait pour le premier semestre
de 2020 si on regarde les les comptes de
la sncf on voit que la sncf a perdu à
peu près deux milliards 4 ce qui est
nettement plus que ce qu'elle avait
perdu dans la même époque en 2019
ce qui veut dire que on va se retrouver
avec 4 milliards peut-être 4 milliards 5
de déficit à la fin de l'année à 4900 de
visite c'est pratiquement la somme qui
est prévu dans le plan si vous voulez
dans le plan de relance
la somme qui est prévu dans le plan de
relance c'est 4 7 milliards
et puis un autre problème on constate
aussi toujours si on regarde les comptes
de la sncf que les investissements ont
baissé or la sncf elle a dramatiquement
besoin aujourd'hui d'investir alors 2
quel ordre justement ces investissements
alors c'est un investissement
on peut les mettre dans trois directions
tout d'abord évidemment si le
gouvernement veut que la sncf remplace
le train pour des voyages de ville en
ville par exemple sur paris toulouse
paris bordeaux
bon il va devoir investir va devoir
investir en matériel va falloir plus de
rames de tgv va aussi falloir investir
dans le réseau il va falloir investir
dans le système de signalisation dans
les caténaires
rappelez-vous l'épisode un petit peu
dramatique où des gens qui venaient
d'hendaye ont été en tgv ont été bloqués
ils ont mis plus de 20 heures pour
revenir sur paris
bref si on veut vraiment assurer la
ponctualité la rapidité de ses
transports oui il faudra investir ça
c'est une évidence
deuxième point c'est le développement
des lignes secondaires
là aussi si on veut développer les
lignes secondaires il va falloir
racheter du matériel
il va falloir des ter qui soit nettement
plus fréquents bien sûr les régions
prennent leur charge dans ses dépenses
mais il faudra d'une manière absolument
évident que l'état apporte je dirais ça
pierre est une pierre plutôt importante
dans ce secteur
et puis on a le problème de la relance
des trains de nuit et de la relance du
fret ferroviaire à la bombe
deux excellentes nouvelles mais il faut
savoir que les trains de nuit gala
pratiquement plus donc ça veut dire si
on veut vraiment relancer les trains de
nuit il faudra racheter massivement du
matériel il faudra de nouveaux
équipements
même chose pour le fret parce que si
vous voulez la question du fret c'est
bien beau de dire qu'il faut développer
le fret ferroviaire
mais l'essentiel c'est comment on fait
passer des charges du camion au train et
puis après du train aux camions ce qu'on
appelle le transport multimodal et là
encore ça va demander des
investissements extrêmement lourd si
vous posez la question jacques ça va
coûter combien
alors si on consulte différents
instituts ou différents bureaux d'études
qui ont travaillé là dessus on aboutit à
une espèce de consensus et à dire qu'il
faudrait entre 15 et 20 milliards
d'investissements en plus des
investissements qui sont déjà prévues
pour les prochaines années
pas de l'investissement global c'est
vraiment de l'investissement
supplémentaire d'ici cinq ans alors mais
vous dites aussi qu'il y à l'ouverture à
la concurrence n'est ce pas oui tout à
fait et ça il faut le savoir c'est que à
partir de la fin de 2020
l'ensemble du réseau ferroviaire sera
justement ouvert à la concurrence alors
cette ouverture à la concurrence
justement elle a déjà eu lieu dans le
domaine du fret et c'est un petit peu ça
qui en réalité a tué le fret avec la
suppression de toute une série de lignes
donc oui la concurrence ça va reposer un
problème extrêmement important à la sncf
et pour quelles raisons alors tout
d'abord
à partir du moment où il ya concurrence
est bien évidemment les concurrents donc
les différentes sociétés qui vont
assurer le transport ferroviaire
elles vont se précipiter sur les lignes
les plus rentables et elles vont
abandonner justement les rings les
lignes qui ne sont pas rentables
or il faut savoir que le transport
ferroviaire
c'est un transport en réseau et donc si
on veut que les gens prennent le tgv
plutôt qu'ils ne prennent la voiture
eh bien il va falloir leur assurer le
transport du premier kilomètre au
dernier kilomètre
autrement dit ça veut dire qu'il faudra
bien sûr qu'il y ait les lignes de tgv
mais il faudra qu'il y ait des
correspondances sur des lignes de ter
qui les amène justement leur destination
le problème du transport c'est que on
voit bien que c'est justement cette
espèce de continuité du premier au
dernier kilomètre qui conte si un
opérateur de transport n'est pas capable
de fournir justement cette espèce de
continuité d'assurer les correspondances
s'il n'en est pas capable et bien à ce
moment là les gens choisiront la voiture
est ce que l'on constate et on l'a
constaté dans plusieurs pays c'est que
la concurrence s'est très souvent la
voie la plus rapide à la privatisation
et c'est souvent la voie la plus rapide
au retour de la voiture comme moyen de
transport donc jeanne vous pensez que la
sncf sera comme vous dites
le dindon de la farce alors je pense
qu'il est trop tôt pour le dire mais on
peut avoir
on peut garder ce risque à l'esprit
parce que si vous voulez derrière cette
ouverture à la concurrence il ya la
privatisation
on sait très bien que l'union européenne
poussent à la privatisation injustement
et de la sncf et de l'ensemble des
opérateurs ferroviaires
or il faut aussi savoir une chose c'est
que cette privatisation cette
concurrence ça ne marche pas la grande
bretagne qui avait été promu pionnière
justement dans le domaine de la
privatisation du secteur ferroviaire et
bien elle est revenue là dessus les
britanniques ont re nationaliser
l'ensemble des sociétés qui s'occupent
du transport ferroviaire donc oui on a
ce problème et globalement on peut se
demander s'il y a bien une cohérence
entre les objectifs qui ont été fixés
par le gouvernement
objectifs qui sont tout à fait
respectable tout à fait défendable par
ailleurs et les moyens 1 qu'il met
justement pour qu'on atteigne ses
objectifs
autrement dit donnera-t-on réellement à
la sncf les moyens financiers pour
qu'elle puisse remplir ses objectifs et
la question restera en suspens on verra
la réponse merci jacques d'avoir été en
direct